[Music]
my name is Cynthia Stevens I was born
and raised here in st. Petersburg
Florida gum one of nine children on the
baby of nine and my parents had me when
I they were in their forties I got an
allowance and I always had a job but
they didn't teach me like the mechanics
maintaining good credit that's what I
was taught
[Music]
right after graduation like it reason I
went into the Navy while I was in the
service I really was not making any
money wasn't you know the salary was
very low trying to raise two kids after
that salary was very difficult when I
got out of the service my sister was
like you should go into the nursing
severe so I started taking I had to
start from the bottom so I just kind of
worked every weekend and on you know
just kind of work my schedule around
school but I still had to pick up days I
had to support my parents so they really
helped me out alive and I knew the ins
would justify to me I graduated from the
anesthesia program start working and I'm
thinking who I'm making a big book so I
can do it but I was talking to dye the
eating and I was like oh what area do
you like what you know tell me what area
what kind of car do you have whatever
trying to figure out what kind of car I
want
so Dada even gave me the Total Money
Makeover book for Christmas as a
Christmas gift I could not put it down
I stayed up reading it and it just like
a light bulb just immediately came on so
I'm like I don't have it together this
is a mess
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the hardest thing for me during this
debt journey not being able to live the
lifestyle that I felt at the time I
deserved that first year was the hardest
for me once I got into a routine and a
role it became easy and you learn to you
learn better have it it just takes time
you just have to go through the process
you're trying to impress people that you
don't even know and that's not you my
hair those clothes it's not me that's
not who I am you just have to live
within your means and you have to take
responsibility for yourself and for your
actions if you have a day you pay the
debt at the time we could sell back our
vacations if we didn't use it we got a
Christmas bonus any extra money I could
get I would use it and using cash and
figuring out okay once it's gone it's
gone so I really need to watch it and be
mindful of it your boundaries are only
the boundaries that you set for yourself
I'm not afraid anymore and I look
forward to the future
[Music]
being single going through the baby
steps is bittersweet
you don't have to be accountable to
anybody but you don't have anybody to be
accountable to I really think though the
radio show in the podcasts are really
good you can see other people and you
can hear their ideas and see what
they've done so I kind of use the radio
show in the podcast as an outreach to
get support I feel many people can make
it excuses for why they cannot get out
of there your race creed color sex is
not a determinant factor of your
experience on this debt free journey you
can do it it's for everyone that that
has the mindset to do it you you have to
sacrifice some things but you can do it
I really never see myself being college
educated so I didn't see myself being
able to accomplish much but you have to
believe in yourself so it took me four
and a half years to pay off two hundred
and twenty thousand dollars and the
reason I felt that it'd be so important
to pay it off is that I did not want
that weight on my shoulders for the rest
of my life because I felt like I will
always have student loan debt and I
would always have you know died owing
someone it was just a small sacrifice
for me to be able to stick to the plan
and do what I needed to do to get out of
debt and do better for myself and for my
students one two three
yes you
and that's it yes all your single moms
out there listening if you don't think
it can be done that was for you
[Music]